if you have trouble keeping track of
things like your car car keys glasses or
even the remote control we've got some
simple solutions for you cnet's
editorial director dan ackerman is here
with the newest gadgets and apps to help
you keep tabs on all of your stuff like
that okay so uh dan we've all been there
we're leaving some place and we're like
and you can't find it and you just feel
like a complete idiot you have something
that could help you're either in the
parking lot you're looking for it on the
street there's hardware stuff there's
software stuff you can do i saw
something called the zeus that plugs
into the power port on your car gives
you a couple usb things but more
importantly it's got an app and when you
turn off the car it pings the app with
the last location of your car so you can
just be out there and open it up and go
okay that's where i parked and it's like
40 bucks and uh it doesn't automatically
when you turn the car off now if you use
an app you can use like google maps and
you can open it up and click on the blue
dot where you are and say i parked here
it'll remember that but you have to
remember to do that when you get out of
the car but that works too and i use an
app called spot angels that also does
that and shows me the parking rules for
where i am so i know alternate side of
the street parking i got to move on
tuesday so you can do hardware
i find that very handy as somebody who
really never knows what's happening with
that so you were able to find your
glasses this morning they're on your
face yeah yeah that's a win if you had
not been able to find them you got
anything to help on that front okay if i
had this when i was a kid my parents
would have been much happier because i
would lose we have a picture of that
actually do we yes
oh damn oh man there they are i bet you
i lost those glasses the next day
and now you're so cute how old are you
how old are you you've been rocking
glasses for a long time i gotta say
that's gotta be fourth fifth grade
whatever however old you are styling
glasses is very very i think it's coming
back yeah i think it's called the room
with some cool frames on huh
and now you can grab this little guy
it's called an orbit and it's very small
it's a little bluetooth tracker you see
it goes right on your glasses here
uh and it's not too bulky it's not too
bulky and i just opened up the app i
there you go i rang my glasses wait so
you could put that on anything though
right you could but it's made for you
know eyeglasses things there are a
million other things you can put on
other stuff but those are too bulky to
put on your glasses it's bluetooth range
you know 30 or 40 meters okay
so you have something for the remote
control i always love this scene in the
bedroom with the remote control you're
going like oh my god
yeah trying to find it why don't they
have that built in a couple of them
actually do have it built in but most
don't including like the apple tv remote
so you know
yeah from tile and air tanks from apple
these are used to track everything i
like the tile has this little one that's
sticky on the back it's very small and a
lot of people put these on the back of
the remote and then again you just ring
it from the app they also make like a
credit card size one you can put in your
wallet
the traditional kind of car key style
one or house key one and of course the
air tag from apple that's their version
of it and that goes in everything i need
a couple of those people make a ton of
little clips and holders for it so you
can put it on you know your luggage but
lately you've been reading about people
getting in trouble because they're using
it to track people who don't want to be
tracked is there a way to safety
yeah apple has done a pretty good job i
hate to give people credit but i will
give apple credit here and these other
companies that they have actually done a
good job of evolving these ecosystems
when they find out how people are
abusing them right so now for example if
an air tag that someone else owns is
moving along with you in sync but the
owner is not there you'll get an alert
saying somebody else's air tag is
shadowing you i just want to make sure
you know that or it'll beep what about
that phone case right yeah what's going
on oh man so talking about losing things
when kovitz started the first thing i
got rid of was my wallet i just keep a
couple of you know cards in my phone
case uh so my kid wanted one of those
kid debit cards i said okay but how are
you not going to lose it i need to get
you a case where it has a secret pocket
in the back a whole compartment for your
card you put it in there slide it shut
it's from spigen it's like 20 bucks and
it's actually a really good protective
case my kid has had this for a year has
not lost his debit card has not broken
his phone so i feel like that's a good
case and you can put your cards in there
unlike
and you really have to put some pressure
on it in order to open it unlike my
little wallet style one where the cards
just fly out every time i open the phone
and you want to protect your cbs
identity card there that's right you
want to keep that very sexy
uh yeah i i think i have to get one of
those you have one of those on the back
you can like slide out probably when you
take one thing out the card comes
offline
it's like i'm dealing a whole hand of
cards to the table that's amazing you've
got stuff for pets too you know it's
interesting a lot of people put
something like an air tag on their pet
there are other versions you can do
whistle has something that it's more
expensive it's about 120 bucks and you
have to have a subscription every month
because it's real gps like full on
mobile you know
go we'll be connections back we'll find
you later all right let me get that
phone case come on we'll get that